boy did he do that because he mentioned
in a press conference he didn't listen
to you he didn't listen to money Robles
he's trying like in mime ahmed may Allah
have mercy on him on his deathbed he was
seen not yet not yet and his sons asked
him why was you seeing that
[Music]
by any means
before the video starts guys check our
sponsors and natures blends they
specialize in premium Ethiopian black
seed products their products are
fantastic health supplements and also
from the Sunnah the website is in the
description link below you can also use
the discount code Salam 10 for 10% of
their products what are you guys waiting
for
Salam alaikum where I mentor a better
care to brothers and sisters in the
offense hope you guys win inshallah
welcome to this video we're gonna be
discussing the fights that happen
between Anthony Joshua and Anthony and
the race is now for us that always at
one place almost upon one of the most
noise with the most rest or praise glory
and gratitude belong to him now I want
to make something clear
we know boxing is Haram it is not
permissible to hit the face because we
know that was Fonterra made Adam created
Adam with his own hands yeah the way
that fits his majesty
not the hands that our hands yeah so you
know we affirm that to allah subhanho wa
taala but anyway so basically that
that's this is this claim that i wants
me because i want to see my book
glorifying this however there was some
very very very strong points but this
this remind is actually going to make me
change your life it's very fundamental
reason why he lost yeah this is very
profound I don't think anybody's come
from from this angle this is his father
look at what his father says and we're
going to connect this to us as Muslims
our reality our life and our tests and
our force that we have let's listen and
we're gonna learn some very key lessons
what was it important just over stone
well why did he do that because he
mentioned in the press conference he
didn't listen to you so now he's talking
about that he put on extra weight which
may have slowed him down etc he wasn't
taking care of himself Excel etc this
could we can relive this well I balanced
it sometimes you need to ponder hellix
things that you hear you ever it may be
for Muslims or Muslims you have to
connect that to yourself and your
religion and your hereafter he put on
weight that slowed him down we know that
we can connect this to ourself what how
put on weight okay we're not gonna talk
about physical weight putting on sins
what happens is when we carry on putting
these sins what
does it has a black dot on the heart and
if these dots increase the heart becomes
hard and when it sees the truth it does
not recognize it buck
yeah it doesn't recognize it so I take
from this when he says it put on weight
if you didn't pour that way he would
have won in the ring you need to see the
ring as your fight against Shaitaan
yeah that's your fight against Shaitaan
you know
so over here we can relate that to our
self and be like hold on a second all
these sins that we've put on so when
we're doing since constantly constant
constant
how is it going to impact us of course
it's gonna impact you in the wrong way
of course it is so that's one thing
number two what was he not listening to
what was he doing that SOI to boxing so
in the billion he said that he wasn't
listen to his coach he wasn't listening
to you look we can connect with this
it's not comparison or an analogy that
he wasn't listen when we don't listen to
our line his messenger yeah look look I
mean it was one like this is amazing
think about you do it really listen a
lot in this messenger you don't listen
to her - messenger we're going to
failure we're gonna feel the fight will
Shaitaan here he's talking about his
coach and himself but why I can see it
from that is my own life from that okay
if I don't listen Alliance mission in
this specific aspect I'm going to suffer
[Music]
the fame came now this isn't something
an analogy an example that we can take
literally why because when the fame gets
you whoever you maybe do the fame gets
to you it's owes and people's minds it
hits your head and you start thinking to
yourself yeah I'm the I'm ears you know
I'm the one et cetera and what you do is
you tie your hope and Happiness into
that and you make that thing your
everything and when the faintest you
sometimes sometimes you can be all over
the place and we've seen that with many
youtubers sadly Muslims and non-muslims
who they themselves will get caught up
in the whole scene and what happens is
it all starts with stomach videos and
then you see going down music videos
girls then are you name it and this is
how she's longest you faint that's
number one and that's one of the reasons
why and the race I'm sorry countenance
and the ruse and the ruse lost
yeah he was with world Royce he was his
friend he was throwing party again again
this can relate to our life the cars the
money the friends bad friends
the partying yeah the harem activities
etc friends Allah says in Auckland up in
surah fatah if I'm not mistaken it talks
about story of a man who'll be in Jannah
and he will allow open a window for him
to look into the Hellfire and he was
seized friends there and he will say if
only I did not stop hanging with hanging
around with you I was going to be in
there with you
so subhanAllah brothers this is look at
that and then it comes back to them the
faint but I mean the cars yeah you're
just you know look in your amazing
cetera and what's that doing is that
that's diverging you from your focus
like and the ruse when he lost what was
his focus went well got the money the
car brother being one what happens is
you go in your comfort zone you start to
think you're untouchable
yeah invincible yeah and this is what
faroan faroan said he I am God I am God
want me even think that because he for I
have all the power I can do whatever I
like sometimes when you have money the
riches and all of that you feel like a
nobody can touch you and it's good for
allah subhanho wa taala to humble you
inshallah and as you can see as he lost
the boxing match to Anthony Joshua his
focus was not in place and he was busy
with this kind of stuff and this is
brilliant it's Korean listen come on
what can we put in that place for and
the Sunnah yes
you're not listening the pulsar's
haven't seen something I knew that no I
know I'm doing the I know better
Oh some people rejected Eve no and no
better arrogance yeah
oh this I don't understand and said if
that's what I'll fry against the wall I
don't want to see the Quran I know what
I'm doing you think you know what you're
doing and what happens is failure
failure hits why because you're not
preparing yourself you're not ready in
any way shape or form you fill your body
food yes you feel about your food you go
to the gym to do so a body is in good
shape when it comes to the soul you
deprive it you give it no food and when
it comes to problems which you're going
to face every single one of us we're
gonna be tested when you quench it down
comes to you with an uppercut
man you're sleeping
why because he wasn't ready for he was
too busy was somewhere else
he can come with us and stay in the
house he didn't want to stay with us he
was staying with his friend it was a
worse
doing and we're not gonna have anyone on
the day judgment see this to us except
ourselves this is going to be a scene
you know what you didn't do this you
didn't do that you got caught with this
and unless the panel it's how it's gonna
tell us what did you do what did you
prepare
yeah was you preparing you know the camp
was you preparing was you ready because
you're gonna feel you're gonna face face
rates on this is your boxing ring this
is the boxing match you can have the ups
and downs I have my ups and downs I've
had my lowest of the lows yes and I'm
going through stuff is for myself but
this is your boxing match your friends
have to be the right friends the car
that you drive like I'm gonna don't get
caught up with it yeah like oh it has to
be this etc all these things that camp
that you're in that the stuff that
you're reading whatever you're giving
your body it has to be halal yes what if
consume has to be halal you actually
should be halal yeah try your best
your company's what you hear what I hear
should be Helen and that is the reason
why brothers and sisters when you go
into that zone what happens is and the
and II lost why because he put his
guards down he was in a comfort zone and
that's what shaitaan does one of the
reasons why allah subhanho wa taala does
not tell us two things the day of
judgment and when we're gonna die is
because we'll be too comfortable if we
you stood okay you gonna buy a 30-7 got
time to go over let me go have fun
and then Yugi I'm trying to say that's
the reason why love doesn't tell us the
day of judgment and that why cuz we
should be prepared you look around you
and I've done another video which you
guys can watch about the rapper who
passed away you see this rappers dying
as well anytime you can go like imam
ahmed may allah have mercy on him on his
deathbed he was saying not yet not yet
and his sons asked him why was you
saying that he says Shaitaan came to me
in a form of a man and he said I met you
you one man you one and he was saying
not yet not yet why because he was
seeing I'm not done yet the moment my
son is taking the earth but I'm
not putting my guards down not yet not
yet in my Mohammed look at this
beautiful narration that was narrated by
his sons look at the beauty confidence
sisters that's the reason why Allah
doesn't mention I would definitely
adjust why we have to be prepared all
the time like a boxing ring your gods
have to have to be up because Shaitaan
is an enemy take him as an enemy take
him as an enemy he hates your guts take
him as an enemy and fights him be ready
and how he's gonna be ready no oh I went
out fight I'm gonna say like no no no no
no you need to make sure that you are
prepared equipped well enforced yes well
we've got your bill ready when he comes
bang bang bang bang you're ready you can
absorb it but if you're not ready
just like Andy yeah go sparked a
facepalm yeah until you sparked him yeah
but I'm not girlfriend it was wrong I'm
saying you're gonna get hit and then
what's gonna happen regrets oh I should
have done this and this is good if you
have gone through this and you realize
anything you know I made this mistake
this is beautiful this is that your
coach oh how do we I'm not saying that I
was named beautiful names belong to
Allah go back to Allah you go back to
Allah subhana wa salli ya and what do
you do you get a lot and his messenger
to prepare you you ask Allah for help
you train them that camp
you don't let these thing distract you
and then have your keen certainty in the
hereafter and a focus yeah nobody seen
don't have fun be focused and when you
focus in sha Allah on the day of
judgement when you're there you've
knocked Shaitaan spark out and inshallah
janitor 4000 Allah then you can have
your Rolls Royce
you can have your parties you can have
your friends you can chill you can fly
go into a chocolate River whatever you
want to do brothers and sisters I think
this was a beautiful reminder for all of
us and one lie it really resonated with
myself is wrong may Allah bless you guys
for watching this also do not forget to
watch the video of why Anthony Joshua
said bismillah and also a replica juice
I don't know who is died watch that
video is when inshallah and do not
forget to share promised mother Janice
channel as well brilliant videos he Jobs
a channel the rest I are are etc may
Allah bless you guys any more videos you
want to react to do let me know a lot so
next time assalamu alaikum warahmatullah
wabarakatuh